siguen los confinamientos masivos en
china esta vez le ha tocado hay un sol
una ciudad de la provincia central de
henán que cuenta con algo más de un
millón de habitantes es una población
ridícula si la comparamos con las
magnitudes chinas pero lo relevante es
que la decisión se ha tomado tras haber
sido detectados apenas tres casos
asintomáticos lo que revela que el
control se acentúa en china a medida que
se acercan los juegos olímpicos de pekín
también ha sido confinada la población
de varios distritos de la ciudad costera
de ningbó tras haber sido localizado un
brote en una fábrica textil por ahora
son solo las zonas más cercanas a esa
fábrica pero si los confinamientos se
extendieran podrían poner en riesgo la
cadena de suministros global porque
nimbo cuenta con uno de los puertos más
importantes de china y mientras tanto
cyan cumple ya con su segunda semana de
encierros estrictos y su octava ronda de
tests sobre sus 13 millones de
habitantes la noticia buena es que los
casos al fin han empezado a caer hoy por
segundo día consecutivo se bajaba del
centenar de casos la noticia mala es que
en algunas zonas de la ciudad el
suministro de alimentos está fallando lo
que está provocado quejas de la
población en las redes sociales